you know I'm a bit in the podcast world
and you've been doing it for a long time
very successfully and I know you do this
podcast with Nicole Byer I'm a big fan
of hers as well and so the idea working
together is fantastic and the podcast is
called newcomers can you tell me what is
newcomers mean what's that theme for the
podcast cuz it sounds interesting yes
each season we're gonna watch something
we've never seen before and the first
season is all about Star Wars and
neither of us had ever seen I mean any
of it we barely knew anything going in
and we've now seen all of it and I feel
very informed and I feel ready to move
on
what are ringing endorsement
[Laughter]
well I mean there's so much and like one
of the things that I think about with
this with going through this podcast is
like everybody who's a huge fan of Star
Wars you get like 10 years between each
movie basically so you're really excited
you're happy that it's like really long
like there's so much to like figure out
and dissect and like new technology and
we're just watching it all in a span of
a few months so like every week I'm
watching another Star Wars movie or like
a series or like an Ewok movie which is
a spin-off that like is crazy and we're
just spending so much time like watching
these movies talking about them
dissecting them we have on guests who
are really passionate about it so it
helps to balance because we're usually
confused or like mad about something but
it's been really fun I'm curious did you
have a favorite character after watching
all of it not knowing anything and then
watching all of the Star Wars catalog
did you come away with like okay this is
my obsession yeah a couple well Kohl's
is Jar Jar Binks so I think that's
amazing because like people were really
upset about Jar Jar back in the day but
I love pores I loved Babu Frick and I
get what I'm saying this is like really
weird for me
I loved Babu Frick and I love yeah wow
really going on a limb with Yoda well
you have to pick one classic you
mentioned a walks I remember being very
irritated by he walks when they showed
up in the Star Wars franchise yeah I
love them I think there's
so cute and funny and they're so great
there you have to Google this there's a
Today Show clip with Al Roker where
there are Ewoks and they're there I
don't know why they're there I guess
it's like just an episode where that was
connected somehow
but they start like grinding on him and
like grinding on the floor and doing
like the moonwalk and it's amazing you
know I heard that this clip existed and
we have it ready and I'm look I don't
want to disappoint our viewers so let's
take a look at the Ewoks on the Today
Show was quickly and that was a day
where there was really serious news if
there was just an in a tional and
incredibly big you know that was that
was the tragedy and then I blew up in
Russia and they were like we're gonna
get to that but first he walks humping
dry humping Al Roker season two okay you
did Star Wars what season two gonna be
it's gonna be Lord of the Rings you've
never watched those no and do you know
them actually I have to say I've watched
them because over the years I had you
know what they were making those movies
we had all the people that were in the
movies come on the show about them so I
would watch the movies and I really
liked them but half the time I don't
know what anyone's talking about
I think that's gonna be a big problem
for us because we can't keep track of
storylines or names like at all in Star
Wars and I heard that there are more
names and they all have nicknames in
Lord of the Rings and every movie is
three-and-a-half hours which is longer
than Star Wars so I'm feeling nervous
there are beautiful films and the
performances are really great and I find
them to be really majestic and they take
you away so in all those reasons it's
great but then there's a lot of we must
go to build a Shia and fine crowd Rahman
and then he'll take us to more Dom
and I don't know what we're talking
about and I'm you just reenact them for
us and just like have that be with the
podcast there's just so many different
shires and places and then there are
elves that don't like everyone's sort of
racist towards each other like elves
don't like you know there's always these
biases and and you think like why do
elves not like you know whatever gnomes
and why do gnomes hate trolls and why -
fairies yeah just it's craziness but you
don't have to always know what's going
on well that's good cuz I just won't I'm
sure I try to like I pay very close
attention and sometimes I even record
myself watching the movie as I go watch
along that people can listen too so it
helps me like focus and I'm like who's
that guy and then my husband will
explain something and I'll still then go
to go into the podcast to have no idea
what I watched like it's it's very hard
for it to stay in here right right well
it's not just you it's just I'm
constantly having trouble knowing what's
happening in a movie
even simple movies Wizard of Oz they're
literally following a yellow brick road
they're saying no they're about my
children are saying calm down this is
what you're still on the yellow brick
road and the witch is trying to stop
them and other than that it's pretty
linear why